We're going to do like 15 minutes of
just open flash talks. Uh so I'm going
to ask uh Ben, our AV guy, to uh make
sure that we have 3 minutes on the clock
for everyone. No more than 3 minutes. Uh
but anything that you want to talk
about? Uh we'll just kind of open the
floor. a couple ideas,
something a framework that you think we
should talk about, a bit of research
that you wanted to present, uh, or just
a straight up rose bud thorn, something
that you learned that you're excited to
put to use, something you want to build,
uh, something that you learned that
you're worried about. So, Gotti, do you
want to you want to kick it off and run
it? And I'll hold the audience mic.
>> So, I found a few people in the hallway.
So if I talked to you about having 30
seconds to one minute to talk about
something and you were foolish enough to
say yes, please come up. Please come up.
I think uh let me read the list.
So we have Gregnotch, right?
We have Ilia.
You guys just start coming up here and
then whoever has some thought on the
topic they would like to share, please
just start lining up here. We'll kick
you off. Very
no longer working. There we go. So Ilia
is here. Perfect. So I'll start and
share a thought. We're all doomed.
No, nobody buys that. Okay, then in that
case, you heard enough from me. Let's
give it to Ilia. And I'll just say
before I speak, Ilia is one of the
smartest people in AI security. Not
because I say so, but because the world
decided so. He's the guy behind Camel.
So, I'm going to give it to him and I'm
going to count 30 seconds. Although
Aaron is nice with the three minutes.
Go.
>> Hello. I wouldn't call myself the
smartest person in the room. Definitely
not. I agree with the doomed assessment,
but I think we can enable more things
than disable. So, I think my hot take,
I've written papers about this. The most
triggering one especially if you're a
cryptographer I was chatting with some
cryptographers is that I think uh
trusted AI models enable a new kind of
private inference whereby you don't need
cryptography anymore. So normally you
need cryptography because say I wanted
to pass a message to Gddy but he lives
in another country and somebody travels
there. So I need to trust a third party
to give my message to and pass it on.
Right? But basically what I'm arguing is
that this models for many use cases can
become such trusted models under quite
different trust assumptions that we
commonly used to to give you an example
like with cryptographers I tend to talk
about Yao millionaires problem. Let's
say I have some money, Gaddy has some
money. We want to find who's richer
without showing each other how much
money we have. We can imagine a setup in
which we both agree on the model. Let's
say we say Germanma models are unbiased
for the purposes we tested them. They
can do this. We both agree on the prompt
that goes into the model like which
number is bigger, the first or the
second? We both agree that we type in
into the keyboard connected into the
model a number. And then we both agree
that the output of the model can only be
the first or the second and nothing but.
And in this setup it becomes quite clear
that you no longer need to put this
complex crazy complex FH scheme inside
and then bam it works. And I think the
killer application for this is in
trusted execution environments where
people don't want to give you the code
to run at station over. What you can do
is you can load the model to become a
private auditor and ask questions about
the code base that is loaded inside over
which you can't compute hashes. And uh
yeah so I think we we live in the world
in which this uh models can enable like
private inference of a new kind for for
many of the problems.
I don't know if it was a half half a
minute
thank you Ilia Greg run in come on
people line up just it can be a thought
like my god I love cloud code. Anybody
wants to say that my god I love cloud
code. cursor co-pilot. Anybody just if
you have a thought, if something hit you
during this conference, we're only going
to do this for a few minutes. Come up.
You're up. Awesome. Uh, hi, I'm Greg.
I'm I'm the chief security officer for
Expel. Um, I don't know about you guys,
but I'm like utterly blown away by some
of the stuff that I heard here this the
past two days. Like on like my mind is
like full of like the new possibilities
and like frankly some of them are
amazing and some of them are terrifying.
Um, but I think one of the things I
really took away from this is we are
absolutely not ready for this for what's
happening right now. Um, and we I think
I have two asks for everybody that's
here. One, we got to go out and make
sure that our companies and our families
and our friends understand what happened
here the the past two days and the and
the new ideas and the things that are
coming. We have to go out and make sure
that we're getting our companies and our
families ready. And number two, my
second ask is if you still got any AI
skeptics in your network, if you still
got anyone you talk to who's like not
sure this is real or this is coming,
those are the people we need to reach
out and grab a hold of and give a hug
because they have no idea what's coming.
So, I want to thank you all for an
amazing two days. I really feel like we
marked a moment together and I'm looking
forward to doing it again. Thank you.
Hey. Uh, so I'm Chris Blanco. I'm here
from ClickUp. I'm the head of
application security over there. And I
do a lot of product design as well. Um,
and that's just because that's what I've
done a lot in my career. And at ClickUp,
it's become really important because
here we're dealing with a situation that
I haven't heard very many people here
talk about yet where you're developing
product. And as you're developing
product, you're realizing that you're
building a platform for agents to run on
top of. And so for context like what
ClickUp has is this space where
everyone's got a workspace that's
combining all your productivity tools
into one place. Context is all
available. It makes our agents really
powerful and we control like an agent
system prompt and otherwise developers
uh users get to put their own things on
top of it with tools integrated MCP
service and etc. And I'm really growing
concerned about this um because we are
creating the situation which is
different from what all of you have
talked about. A lot of us have talked
about things that are like what I'll
coin as a single player problem where
you've got one agent and you're trying
to monitor the actions of that one agent
on that one endpoint and how it
interacts with those other systems. But
I'm worried about what I'll call a
gossip problem in this multiplayer
environment where we've got different
people with different scopes of access
with different agents that might have
different contexts and access to
different external systems and all of
them are really eager to please you and
each other and they're listening to each
other because they're all in the same
workspace. And so it's really trivial
for one bit of information to go from
one agent to another faster than anyone
can reasonably control it. and data
control is quickly going out the window
despite us having the ability to add a
check at first time of first agent
check. But if someone summarizes
something as an intent and drops in some
other object, we quickly have to start
thinking about well where the hell else
is that going to go? And that's going
faster than we can reasonably control.
And so like I think about this a lot.
Um, there are probably some intelligent
things that we can do within our own
workspace to tag information that says
something like, well, hey, I know that
that is coming from an external source.
But anyway, I I probably would be
interested in talking to some other
people about this afterwards. Uh, so if
you're interested in product design, let
me know.
Is that timer working?
>> Cool. Hi folks, my name is Ariana. I'm
super excited to be here. Thank you. Um,
I just want to spend a minute and 54
seconds or less talking about how I'm a
cyber security researcher who was an AI
skeptic and is no longer. And so my
background is in datadriven security. I
take a bunch of data about the world and
try to figure out how can we make things
safer for people across the internet.
And recently I have really been drawn to
this uh problem of pig butchering. Who
has gotten a text that says, "Hey John,
what's up? Are we ready for golf?"
Yeah. Hey, exactly. Great. Great. Um, it
turns out that this sort of scam is new.
It's growing in size. It is a
multi-billion dollar industry. And I, as
a researcher, have data that shows that
they are not using AI yet to scale it,
right? There's a ton of news on this.
Um, this problem is being propagated by
unfortunately human trafficking victims.
However, they can start to use AI to
scale even more, make it smarter, make
it better, and enact more harm. And so,
I am with a team right now, and we are
trying to defend people by combining
cyber security and AI. 45 seconds uh to
to stop this problem. And so as someone
who has recently become become less of
an AI skeptic, I'd like to propose to
folks to think about the ways that we
can use AI defensively to protect
victim, to protect our families, to
protect our friends because these
problems are growing in size. They are
growing in scale. They're going to start
using the AI tools. We should as well.
Thanks, folks. I'm Ariana.
>> Thank you.
Hi everyone. I'm probably going to be
faster than two minutes. Uh my name is
Art. I uh represent today a team at my
company called Kraken. We are kind of
like a mix of uh people with um let's
call a lot of cyber warfare specifically
exposure um AI researchers as well as
commercial cyber researchers. And I'm
here today to just ask you maybe for
some feedback. Check out our uh latest
research on um mechanistic
interpretability of some of the LLMs
where we uh do feature ablation and
obliteration of some of the biggest
models out there and we um probably one
of the only teams who we kind of pitch
figured out a so-called domain specific
cyber security specific feature
ablation. I would want to ask uh AI
researchers out here. Um maybe maybe I
can do it this way. So there is a
website C R A CN.ai.
Uh go to blog, check out our research,
give us feedback. You can find me on
LinkedIn. Thank you.
>> Hey, good afternoon everybody. I'm Rob
Joyce, um, former NSA, and I'm here to
implore the CISOs and the security teams
who are in attendance to think about
getting Agentic at Agentic red teaming
running on your networks continuously.
Why? Um, I'll I'll tell you past life I
led the hackers of NSA and we succeeded
not because we had amazing people, which
we did, not because we had some amazing
tools, which we did, but because we knew
more about the networks than the people
who owned them, operated, and defended
them, and sometimes more than the
security products that they used inside
the the networks themselves. And so what
I'm telling you is the agentic wave
that's coming at us right now is doing
that detailed research. It's finding the
hidden latent flaws. It's finding the uh
the unpatched pieces. It's finding the
the shadow it and it's finding the
misconfigurations at scope and scale.
And so you want to pay for that agentic
red teaming because whether you like it
or not, somebody's going to do it to you
and you're going to want to get the
outcomes and outputs of that agentic
survey. So thanks.
>> Hi, I'm Andrew. I'm here because I
wanted a new fun fact, which is talking
after Rob Joyce. Um
actually uh I just had a quick idea from
the last talk in terms of moving from
the limitations of cloud code. You have
like an agent that's local. How do I get
it to becoming basically its own self um
fulfilling uh it has the context that it
needs you know running on its own agent
like I do security operations. I have a
triage agent that I run in cloud code.
Um, now I need to spend another few
hours making sure that it runs in a loop
like in a system like times and it has
all the contexts that it needs. Um, how
do I do that really? Well, I have no
idea. So, I'm going to go and screw
around and fight out and then I'm going
to do it again the next week for the
next problem. So, I don't know if this
is a new startup idea for somebody
because I don't want to do that. But, if
you can make that easier for me, I'll
pay you to do it.
Thank you.
Hello. Um, I just wanted to come up and
say one thing that I didn't really hear
a lot about that I'm taking a huge
interest in is local models. I know that
we're using the cloud and the power
there uh to do some really amazing stuff
agentic stuff but there is local models
that are capable and they will finish
the last 10% that claude might not be
willing to do might push back on and uh
if you just buy a few GPUs you can get
those things to to happen and um so if
anybody's running local stuff I have
eight 3090s and and it's fantastic. It's
working great. So, uh, come and talk to
me after. Thanks.
>> It's kind of ironic. I was just about to
say like this is one of the greatest
conferences that didn't have any
pitches. I didn't feel like people were
selling stuff. And so, I I hope that
culture like stays during the next
event. Um, I know everyone or most
people here on Slack. I know when I go
back to work, I'm going to be in my own
and I but I will poke back in every now
and then. I'm hoping everyone else does
because I think we already have a great
community on that Slack. Um, and
unprompted. So stay in touch. Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Hey everybody, my name is Josh. Uh
massivecale.ai.
One thing um really focused on is trying
to simplify
all of these messages to your leaders.
Um this started because my wife is very
interested in AI, but she never
understood anything I'm talking about.
and everything you guys talked about
here. Amazing. Um, if you saw Carl's
talk yesterday,
um,
intercepting attention layers within a
model to put quality gates, like
amazing, mind-blowing. I think it makes
sense to all of us.
But to the point about going home and
teaching everybody what what we're
facing, I think um, think about
simplifying this. And I like to think
about it as like an intern or a digital
employee.
Um the way I've explained it to some of
the leaders that have resonated is, you
know, would you give your intern keys to
the safe um a very difficult job or
would you make them earn earn autonomy?
Uh trust is earned. It's not granted. Um
when I explain these things to the
leaders I work with, they they get it.
Um, I just published a gentic trust
framework on cloud security allianc's
blog. It talks about five simple
questions that are very simple. Who are
you? Identity. What are you doing?
Behavior. Um, where are you going?
Segmentation. What are you eating and
what are you serving? Data inputs. Data
governance. Um, and what if you go
rogue, which is anomaly detection,
right? It's it's five very simple
questions. And if you think about a Gent
AI as a digital worker and you explain
these five questions, the normies get
it, right? If you can get the normies to
get it, then they can actually do
something about it. Check it out.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi everyone. It's an amazing conference.
Thank you. Um, Zraini from Raini
Ramolingum from Snowflake. Um I we've
heard so much about all of the problems
and all of the threats um associated
with AI and all the enterprises are
adopting AI at breakneck speed including
ours and the biggest challenge um you
know being on the enterprise security
side is that all of most of the AI tools
that are adopted in the enterprise do
not have enterprisegrade controls
security controls and features get
released But you know security controls
are an afterthought or we have to work
with vendors to get them in. So if we
can come together as a community and
actually influence our genai tools and
and you know AI tool vendors to actually
bake in enterprisegrade security
controls as they release features. I
think that would be a great win. And if
anyone's interested in partnering I you
know please hit me up on LinkedIn. Thank
you.